and emotional ariana grande spotted for
the first time since the terrifying
Manchester attack et has a look at
photos of ariana visibly in tears as she
exited a private jet from England on
Tuesday the popstar returned to her
hometown in Florida where she was
greeted by boyfriend Mac Miller who was
waiting outside the plane to comfort
Ariana
[Music]
23 year-old Ariana dressed in all black
was seen giving her Bo a sweet smooch on
the cheek a source close to the
dangerous woman singer told et ariana is
an absolute wreck following the fatal
concert bombing that left at least 22
people dead following the shocking
incident Gayle King spoke to her manager
Scooter Braun I said to scooter is she
okay and he goes no she is not okay
it was very firm about that no she is
not okay no further details on whether
Ariana will suspend her world tour our
source says quote her team is continuing
to assess the situation before they
decide how to move forward I love being
on till I love spending a lot of time
performing with my fans